[Music]
hey
here we are once again can i never think
the audio is working
who knows i don't know
what's that buzzing sound it's the it's
the laptop it's like i'm working so hard
it's doing that
okay yeah cause uh right before like
five minutes before we went on like
pookie decided she's like i want to sit
on the buttons
so she jumped up and sat all over
everything so i don't really know if it
like
adjusted some [ __ ] that i don't know
about or who
[ __ ] knows i don't know what the hell
is going on with this [ __ ] all right we
saw uh the creep show holiday special it
was good
it was pretty good yeah i don't think it
was as good as the halloween one
which was the animated one because i
thought this one was going to be
animated too because i thought that was
just a thing they were going to do and i
kind of liked that idea but this one was
live action
yeah and it's like a mini episode like
40 minutes long yeah i think it was 46
minutes or something like that
yeah where creatures and fighting with
santa claus
yeah this is a bad guy it's funny
well that's it yeah so it was written
and directed by greg nicotero i guess
it's from a short story i can't remember
the name of the author
um because i didn't have my notes but
because we just watched this
like right before we ate lunch because
we didn't uh we didn't watch it last
night because we were too tired like
after the
after the show and i was like even if we
do watch it we won't remember what
happened
but yeah so it's weird because when this
one first started like it's
funny and it's you know it's obviously
going to be a werewolf story
but you don't really know what it has to
do with christmas
until probably like the middle you know
what i'm saying yeah like you kind of
see that it's christmas time because
there's like santas and [ __ ] like that
but you don't really get how the two
things tie together
until about midway through like i don't
want to spoil it too much because i feel
like people might
want to watch it and like let it unfold
the way it unfolds
yeah because it's silly it's pretty it's
pretty ludicrous
but it knows that it's literally yeah
you're not supposed to take it seriously
like the mythology behind it is like
really
i mean basically so it's called
shapeshifters anonymous that's the name
of it
and i mean the setup of it is there's
this guy
whose name is robert weston which i'm
pretty sure
that's because there's a whole bit like
all the characters in this are named
after
like things from other werewolf or where
creature movies like the one
girl that's in the group the one woman
that's in the group is named um
irena which is with the name of the
character that turned into a cat in cat
people
like back in the 40s she does turn into
a guy yeah she turns into a cheetah
and i think in cat people arena turned
into a panther
if i'm remembering it correctly i
haven't seen it in a long time
um and i think like the password to get
into the meeting was landis like john
landis from american werewolf in london
so there's all kind of like little
easter eggs in there i think robert
weston has a callback too but i can't
remember what it's
um what it's for and i think like the
one guy that's in there that never says
anything that's named ryan i think his
last name is chaney like lon chaney so
yeah so he he turns up at this meeting
which is supposed
for shapeshifters anonymous and these
are all people that turn into various
creatures
you know when the moon is full or
whatever and he has started to believe
that he is a werewolf
um stuff starts turning up in his poop
like he like he's blacking out and he
doesn't remember what happens and then
like he starts like pooping out like
buttons and zippers zippers and [ __ ]
like
clothing and he's like i know i didn't
eat this stuff
so it's like that bar was like pretty
funny like the whole the whole thing of
him like sitting in the doctor's office
with the stool sample
and like everybody looking out and stuff
it's pretty like i said it's pretty
so like pretty juvenile and a lot of it
is just set in this one room
you know with the the meetings well like
with them like kind of sniping at each
other and
you know figuring out what's gonna
happen it doesn't really get
like kind of full full-on horror and
full-on christmas until the end and like
i said
the way that santa relates to the wear
creatures is like ridiculous but it's
kind of funny ridiculous
this one's on shutter it's a shutter
exclusive yeah yeah yeah
that we'll see you know with the the new
creep show the show yeah but yeah it's
like i don't i didn't like it as much as
the hollow the animated one the
halloween one the last one with it we
reviewed but um it's still pretty funny
it was it was entertaining like some of
the jokes were pretty funny and it was
had real good animation during the intro
and the outro
and it had uh uh good practical effects
you know it had a bunch of throwback
type stuff in it and
good costumes the acting was good it was
funny
and you know it was all taking place in
one area
they tried to get as much as they could
out of it you know they're fighting off
[ __ ]
whole hordes of santa claus mall santa
clauses and [ __ ] it's just
silly [ __ ] it's funny though and
actually like it seemed like a lot of
the effects were practical because
there's like a lot of monster effects in
it
and um they were really well done like
you can tell it's a low-budget show but
it's like they did a really good job
yes robert weston is wolfman jack's real
name that's right i knew it was
something to do with
werewolves they're asking about uh
finishing the mandalorian the
mandalorian was good i liked it i liked
it a lot too
they're trying to bring bring star wars
back after those
last three movies and trying to take it
back to its roots it was uh it was good
i liked it
i kind of i kind of wonder if i mean
i kind of want to talk about it but i
don't want to say anything in case like
people haven't seen the last episode
i think everybody kind of knows by now i
mean
i'm not well i mean i'm not gonna say
what happened at the end but i also
like now i'm kind of wondering because
i'm assuming since the mandalorian has
been so successful that they're gonna do
a season three and season three
is supposed to be out like at the end of
next year
and but i don't know if the thing that
that like the stinger thing
that they did at the end like after the
credit show that's a difference is that
a spin-off or is that season three
okay that's what i was wondering like it
seems like everybody's wondering they
were gonna make a movie on that topic
instead they're going to make a series
okay that's you know that's how i
understood it but that's going to be a
different spin-off
they're going to be about there's going
to be an ahsoka spin-off there's going
to be a bunch of spin-offs
which that's kind of a cool idea you
know what i mean it's you know it's
almost like keep the quality good
yeah i mean john favreau seems to be
like
kicking ass on this he seems to know
like what understands it what star wars
people
he's not directing all these episodes so
he's putting good people in charge
of it you know he's probably keeping
control of the tone
you know but um yeah i liked it
it just occurred to me that if the thing
that they put the stinger at the end
that kind of can't be season three
because then it wouldn't be a
mandalorian
right it wouldn't be about a mandalorian
anymore so they can't really still call
it the mandalorian
right you know what i'm saying like this
but hopefully that's not too spoilery
i really feel bad if i'm really trying
to like tiptoe around like what happened
in case you didn't see it yet
yeah but um yeah fourth throwdown said
yeah lots of spoilers on youtube
i actually managed to it's weird because
we watched it
friday night and i was already seeing
people
like freaking out about it like on
facebook even like that afternoon so
some people were watching it like
earlier than me and i was really trying
not to lie was like not looking not
looking like i was scrolling through the
[ __ ]
so i was kind of hoping that i didn't
get it spoiled but it didn't it was a
good episode i mean
it was good to kind of take star wars
back to its roots it wasn't a whole lot
of
it you know but it was just enough um
you know that pro that kind of [ __ ]
probably won't happen again
yeah you know uh but at least not with
those characters
we'll see you know because they they
brought somebody back they used cg with
it it looked okay it didn't look great
but
it was okay yeah it was good for the
purpose for what it was
right i didn't mind it um but you
probably won't see a whole lot of that
i don't like i don't think they'll have
a whole series about that
although it would be wise but how are
you gonna have a whole series around cg
characters
yeah that would get a little a little
bit weird yeah
uncanny valley i think they should they
should have used deep fake
i think that would have worked better
but whatever
i'm not entirely sure how they did that
you know what i mean like they i guess
they did the facial mapping and all that
kind of stuff
i don't think it was not a whole cg
character it was a real person it was
just like with a different face
i think but i don't know um
yeah so like i said i don't want to say
too much but i really really liked
um i really really liked how they ended
up the mandalorian and so so like i said
i'm really kind of
we'll see what happens with the next one
and i'm going to be watching that new
thing like
like you said if it's a spin-off series
that they did like that on the
post-credit sequence i'm like yeah that
looks like it's going to kick ass too
because that's like a whole that's a
whole other plot thread that we could
like follow that's like pretty rad
so yeah so i'm like pretty happy with
the way it's going
um we probably need to watch the clone
wars
i haven't seen any of that yeah i
haven't seen it either i feel like we
need to like
start watching that but it's got god
it's like there's so much stuff that i
got to watch i'm so [ __ ] behind
yeah i'm so bothered finish the
scientology stuff i gotta finish the
scientology thing i have like a bunch of
christmas movies i gotta watch tonight
to review like
two or three of them we gotta watch
christmas movies more
yeah we already saw one today what are
we gonna see
we have to see um okay well
are we going out tomorrow night
well because i have to know because i
have to know if i have to watch
what's happening tomorrow memento oh
[ __ ] that's tomorrow night all right
um so in which case we wouldn't be able
to watch anything
because we would be out so
uh yeah so i need to watch at least one
christmas movie and
maybe the retro movie which i'm not
gonna spoil for people if you're on
patreon you know which one it is because
the votes came in today
but i'm still kind of wore out from last
night
yeah yeah well like i said i mean i can
watch them
all right you can just like no i'll
watch it
you can just like kind of sit there and
yeah and be like yeah
yeah just kind of sleepy right now
glowing turtle says what's the
scientology thing we've been watching
the
leah remedy scientology in the aftermath
yeah on netflix
yeah we talked about it a little bit
last night but on the on the show
three seasons of it yeah we had seen the
first season like years ago when it was
on a
e but netflix has all um all three
seasons on there so we
caught up and we were watching i think
we watched all of season two and then we
were
like i think we just started season
three right a lot of this [ __ ]
a lot of this [ __ ] i watched it as it
was happening that's how i met [ __ ]
agp angry gay pope he was during that
whole scientology
anonymous war that went on back in what
was that 2009
yeah uh mike render and uh
who else what was uh marty marty rathbun
marty rathbun
and all the weird [ __ ] that was showing
up on youtube
thinking the squirrel buster war all
this kind of weird [ __ ]
squirrel scientology and
you hadn't been on youtube back in those
days when all those executives were
leaving the cult
and then the cult was coming to their
houses [ __ ] with them
and they were videotaping it and posted
it on youtube
yeah i think a lot of that shit's gone
now because uh church of scientology has
armies of lawyers
and they sent it they they uh they
threatened to sue youtube and youtube
just gonna rolls with whoever's gonna
cost them you know whoever cost them the
most money you're going to bring youtube
to its knees
which kind of sucked because there's a
lot of good videos of agp
[ __ ] with scientology guards and
harassing them and
you know just not just protesting them
you know there's a lot of really cool
protest videos it's all gone
he was go up to gold gold base and going
up into the mountains and showing all
the [ __ ] razor wire or
what they call ultra barrier and yelling
through the
yelling through the bars and trying to
talk to the scientologists and yeah
scientologists are [ __ ] crazy
you know they're just very yeah it's
hilarious [ __ ]
you know those weird corporate jargon
about squirrel and attack
and [ __ ] what was that one
aotc now what was the one where it meant
like good
vibes in between the two we're just here
for aarc
i think that's what that what it was aa
yeah i can't remember now and they use
all this weird technical jargon
ksw
to describe their spiritual technology
it's yeah and what it does
it's a technology yeah and the uh
scientologists [ __ ] mind [ __ ] each
other even when they're in good
standing they com they're constantly
cussing at each other and trying to
evoke emotions
and because to to to to have
an emotional response is considered a
weakness that's your reactionary
mind is what they called it yeah so
they're all trying to be kind of like
vulcans and in order to but not in the
cool way not in the cool way though
in order to prove that you're a vulcan
is is that you
you dish out all kinds of abuse onto
another scientologist and if they react
then it's a weakness yeah just take it
you know it's all kinds of weird and
they do that's how they fight each other
with their ot powers there's operating
titans
yeah which really it ends up being
basically the kind of [ __ ] you you do it
to each other in the army
or this they got that from l ron hubbard
being you know
being in the navy yeah kind of do that
in the navy too
he's just given a [ __ ]
[ __ ] religious explanation for why
you do it yes they're just toughening
each other up
really you know yeah and becoming
and becoming immune they're trying to
tough each other up and becoming
becoming immune to insults and stuff and
knowing your weaknesses and
you know leaning into it so it doesn't
you know it doesn't bother you
and they make each other wear all these
[ __ ] signs like [ __ ] dick sucker
and [ __ ] that put the [ __ ]
name plate says dick sucker [ __ ] eater
yeah
i think [ __ ] eater was the one was the
one that um
that what's his face had to wear the guy
that's on with leah remini
it just went right out of my head well
when you go on when you go on on netflix
they clean it up a lot when it was on
old youtube it was a
you hear what they really say you know
what i mean and they couldn't
really it was coming back on them you
know what i mean it's making them look
bad
because scientologists say all kinds of
[ __ ] racist and homophobic [ __ ] to
each other
they do indeed and it's homophobic as
[ __ ] mike render thank you yeah mike
rander yeah i just it's like we just
said his name five minutes ago and then
it just went shoop
yeah so they didn't want that getting
out to the public you know so they tried
to stop
all these videos but yeah they're
calling each other all kinds of dick
suckers and this and that and [ __ ]
accusing each other being [ __ ]
homosexual but they do of course they're
doing it in a crude way
nowadays on youtube but back then you
know they were [ __ ] saying it
it's just hilarious you know because the
average person
who wasn't a scientologist would see
this [ __ ] and i didn't know what the
[ __ ] was going on who are these people
that's really how i was introduced to it
what the [ __ ] is the squirrel what
what's this coral
why are they [ __ ] going to this
dude's house why are they spraying
[ __ ]
hoses on each other why are they showing
it with umbrellas
and why are they in a pedal boat it's
[ __ ]
just well they have a second pedal going
by
they have their whole like a whole
jargon
like a whole lingo and it's like if you
just kind of stumble across a video
randomly
you have no idea what they're talking
about because that's like all the
[ __ ] weird phrases
and yeah and acronyms and [ __ ] that they
use
it's like it's it's crazy yeah they go
to the dude's house and dude just sprays
[ __ ] water on him so he just stands
there with an umbrella
so they're sitting there just talking
when he's spraying
[Laughter]
i mean they're dangerous i was like but
they're also ridiculous ridiculous yeah
and i kind of feel like you know
bless south park because i think south
park went a long way toward everyone
thinking that they were a joke
i mean i think a lot of people thought
they were a joke before but i think
south park like really kind of
mainstreamed it yeah they're a ufo cult
basically
pretty much yeah yeah when you get down
to when you get down to the nitty-gritty
of it it's a [ __ ] ufo
yeah putting big cymbals in the ground
so [ __ ] l ron hubbard's [ __ ]
satan or his [ __ ] soul could find his
way back because they believe that they
come back and reincarnated and just
looking weird
every time david misca every time they
share that clip of david miscavige back
in 1986
like at the little scientology
get-together like saying that l ron
hubbard had dropped his body
dropped his body that just like makes me
laugh because i always just feel like
whoops dropped my god damn it's like
driving your keys well they said he was
they said he was healthy and he was like
he was healthy and he
and and he consciously dropped his yeah
he did it
his training into another dimension in
another dimension yeah
they can't say that he was sick or that
he died of a stroke which he did
they couldn't say that because that
would disprove scientology yeah
just scientology but you're supposed to
be healthy forever if not immortal
yeah so they basically said i mean
elrond hubbard is like their deity right
yeah so he couldn't just like
get old and you know and die like a
normal person
so they had to say well he was still
like really healthy and strong and
everything but
he wanted to leave he decided that he
couldn't do any more
like in this body so he had to like he
dropped it he dropped it
yeah like a robe and they believed it
they did it they believed it i was like
you guys
you can hear me in the audience oh
and that's really when science took took
a bad turn because miss cabbage took
over
yeah and that dude was like [ __ ] just
with styling
look we got to go though
look we got to go we still got chocolate
chip cookies to eat and yeah and i'm
you know i'm i don't feel too bad but i
am still kind of sleepy although i did
actually sleep until 8am this morning
which is really late for me
yeah well like i said we gotta we'll
just watch some christmas movies tonight
we can review
[Laughter]
yeah it's always kind of like ever even
in our going-out days when we always
went out saturday night sunday was
always kind of like blah blah because
we're always like hungover and tired and
[ __ ]
all right so uh we'll be back tomorrow
with another
movie review more christmas movies this
week because we're leading up to
christmas day so we'll see you guys
tomorrow
bye